et je jour encore 4 000 Odin sur un
mur d'entre eux, c'est comme si les gens y étaient
ou les copains sont comme ok ok
ce destinataire vertical comme ça
fait le porte-conteneurs juste devant
nous ce gros coup le bleu Holloway
ouais ouais  J'en ai parlé ouais bon
Oh
Ground Zero 500
para LaGuardia Peabody cette partie
va montrer 21 pour défier cette
fête bien les hanches ouais qu'est-ce que
tu veux montrer à tous les transports que
tu veux pousser comme ces canards
qui sortent  vers ces autres navires,
c'est comme le Harper Valley College à l'
intérieur, ils voient ce sport ni non
c'est la grande zone de navigation au nord-est
klaxonnant oh c'est riche pas vraiment la
grande fête je pense que ce ne sont que quelques
bateaux je veux dire qu'il sera  50 100 dollars est-ce que ça
déplace un grand chantier naval en Corée merci
de me laisser bien d'accord Ken à propos du canal il est
comme 250 comme ça pas que nous avons
hâte d'avoir de la nourriture pour 250 comme ça facile
à la femme du canal de Panama vous obtenez de la nourriture
skyhawk  est tun  nel découvrez que
cela jusqu'à 500 pour respirer g16 oscillant
votre dignité qui ira vers le
grand porte-conteneurs bleu dix heures un distributeur de
billets je n'ai pas de chats sont juste
meilleurs à l'
est de l'année nous avons votre trafic est par
PTV 12 pistes endroit pour obtenir le fudge
joli homme pensez-vous qu'ici ils
étaient il suivra la personne qui
va à New York et vous voyez new
york en arrière-plan mais bon vous
aimez ça je vais passer celui-ci  ça
va vers le sud tu penses que c'est un 504 the body
shop echo gulfport river pour la
visite en bateau de croisière j'aurai des heures en direction du sud et
je pointerai pour l'émission télévisée toi et Rob faites
un angle d'inclinaison du coude Delta Bravo d'accord
je vais faire ici Peter maintenant  laissez-moi sortir un
peu là-dessus ouais je vais
faire le tour de la façon dont nous sommes arrivés derrière notre navire ouais
les deux autres jours puis je tournerai et maintenant je me
rejoindrai David d'accord
c'est en train d'être rénové enfin je me
fais une blague
ha no 80 left survive on a direct water
milk at 30 ac  tive gulfport traverser la
rivière supposons que si je peux tous entrer dans la
pièce, il ne vit pas à droite Wow,
laissez-moi vous verser une affaire de famille parce
qu'il tourne ouais nous allons y aller par
moi-même celui-ci peut-être 12
dame éléphant 506 lat longtemps  de la
part de Bajor, ils sont vraiment bien le golf est à
côté de la statue ici à toute pendaison pour
grimper oui probablement bien avec vous quelle
retraite vous êtes autorisé pour un
problème de départ si je ne vais pas monsieur coin le
statut ici 250 300  c'est vrai
Consuela bébé se dirige à nouveau je ouais
adorable merci merci beaucoup de
quoi avons-nous besoin ensuite ce dont nous avons besoin ensuite
est qu'en est-il de faire cette ombre de la statue de la
liberté est un magasin de lumière
qui n'est toujours pas comme oh tu veux dire mon sur
l'évadé  s les gardiens un peu on
est probablement pas mal d'inutiles je
vois encore le bateau hé vois le reflet
ahora toujours aussi argenté zoom avant ouais qu'en est-
il de faire de l'eau à la vieille dame je ne reçois pas
ce petit bateau Sylvain tu
vas  terminer la mission ce soir ok vous
nous  je suis sur le point d'aller plus vite
Oh retard, elle a déjà été exposée d'accord,
alors faites ce que vous voulez faire mon
charlie 1003 pour aller Appa la
balance boxer de cette façon mais ressemble à un
patio 71.1 solide amer il y a un
grand écran salut ralph est un grand écran
ce soir avec une ombre de feu aussi d'
accord nous sommes ce gars ouais qu'en est-il de
1100 Valley Bermuda pouvez-vous faire de l'eau
jusqu'à zoomer dans l'eau sans incliner jusqu'à
manhattan et la statue comme ça ouais
je vais vous dire de le laisser dans l'eau
pendant une minute, je veux dire, je vais prendre un
peu de vitesse, nous irons au
coude de sochi ouais oh je comprends alors ça va
lancer le bâtiment ouais nuit les gens d'accord
vous n'allez pas voir le Batman et
aller jusqu'au bout  vous êtes souvent des statues un peu maladives
qui s'améliorent à nouveau ironiquement alors
ça va ici oh mec
genre de ça nous allons vite savoir comme
ça bien posture ouais nous allons
déchirer votre maison comme une salle de partage de tunnel
[ __ ] n'est-ce pas  juste gaspillé gouverneur 73
il ok
il est mr.  frère
je veux que le saut soit prêt bien être ma
position de concentration leurs flottes atterrissant sur le
problème Roger quand nous étions 11
architectures après 17 camions excitant
quand vous montez la porte ouest un
petit con de Lincoln euh tout droit attendez
une minute les jambes n'étaient pas un problème